First up, our story is we're gonna talk dating etiquette
for the modern dater.
Here's the question,
I like this one, I really love this story.
Mm hm.
When can you ask the person you're seeing
to delete their dating app?
I mean, how juicy is this?
This is literally modern romance.
Absolutely, and you know what
it's like a conversation you have to have.
I had a friend, true story,
she was dating somebody on one of the dating apps
and then she, it was like kind of getting serious.
So she was like, "I'm gonna go
on the dating app and get off now."
And when she logged in, she saw
that he was still on and had just updated all
of his pictures with pictures that she had taken of him.
Oh my God!
Uh huh, and I was like, she was just mortified.
I'm like, well, didn't you have a conversation
with him about, "Are we doing this now?"
And the answer was no, she didn't.
So this just comes down to communication.
Mm hm.
A lot of layers.
Well, Vice actually said,
"When can I ask the person I'm dating to delete Tinder
or you know, any dating app?"
And they say, when this question pops up in your head
maybe it's time to have that larger conversation
about defining the relationship
and it's not about just saying no to other people,
but yes to the one that you're with.
You know, I like your perspective
because I don't think there's a right or a wrong,
you're saying communication is best.
And I don't think relationships is gonna survive
without it period at the beginning, middle or end.
Yeah and if you can't have that conversation of like,
"Are we off the dating apps?",
then you shouldn't be in this relationship, right?
That's like the starter conversation.
Your friend's example is a non-starter for me.
Yeah, bye.
Bye.
All right, next Drew, okay we're getting
into the "Charlie's Angels" spirit,
with Ciara who I love.
HelloGiggles reports that she just posted her latest look
and take a look at this, it is full on Farrah Fawcett.
Yeah, the Farrah flip is showing up, she looks amazing.
She does.
And it's a huge trend, it's now on Tiktok.
Okay.
Oh my God, does that remind me of childhood.
Right? Look, there's Brie Larson.
Would you ever do that?
That Farrah Fawcett flip?
I did it in "Charlie's Angels".
There you are.
There you go.
That was the best wig ever, by the way, I still have it.
You do?
Where?
Yeah.
I cut it.
I like those wigs are so expensive, I'm not kidding.
They're made by master artists, you know
from all over the world, these wigs cost so much money.
So I keep them and then I,
if you're working on a different film
with a different budget, you're like,
"Don't worry, I got a wig in my bag."
I work at "RuPaul's Drag Race",
I know about wigs in the bag.
Exactly, you never throw away a wig.
Not a good one.
You always re-introduce it.
Well, hairstyles always come back around and so
do names apparently because Fatherly reports, a new study
of parents are reaching back to the 1800's
to name them babies.
Researchers at the family history site,
My Heritage crunched census data
to find that Ada,
Nora,
Theodore,
Eliza,
Ella and Walter are all making a comeback.
It's about time Walter made a comeback.
I always think of "Sleepless in Seattle",
when I hear Walter.
While the names of the 1980's and 1990's
like Jessica, Jennifer and Amanda have actually decreased.
And have you met a lot of Rosie, Rosses lately?
No, I haven't.
I'm glad.
I don't know where Ross came from.
I asked my mom and she goes, "I just liked it."
I just thought she was like a fan of Ross Dress For Less.
And then I asked my dad, you know,
"Did you always wanna name me Ross?"
And do you know what he wanted to name me?
What?
Captain,
and I'm furious my name is not Captain,
wouldn't I make a great Captain?
It's never too late.
(Ross laughing)
Thank you.
I cannot even imagine you as any other name.
Well I love a one syllable name,
'cause I'm a busy guy, I got things to do.
You know what I mean, Drew?
I do Ross,
and finally it's time for a brand new segment.
We're putting on our Drew's new spin
on the traditional advice column in, "Ask a Deskspert".
(Ross laughing)
Ross, do it!
"Ask a Deskspert", it just rolls off the tongue.
All right, now Ross and I make no claims
to know any better than anyone else,
but listen, if you have a conundrum, we wanna help.
Oh we wanna help real bad.
I know!
Why do I love giving advice?
It's like my number one thing to do.
It's my favorite thing ever.
And I'm not qualified at all.
Well, I will say I have ascertained extraordinary advice
from great minds throughout my whole life.
So if I can be a funnel of that wisdom,
you know what, let me be that.
And we asked you to submit your questions about life, love
and relationships and Rosie and I
will use our combined years of experience
on this earth to give our best ideas
and advice for you to take or disregard completely.
Rosie, who's our first letter?
All right, love this, we're just helping our friends out.
This is all-
We hope.
We hope, this letter says, "Dexperts."
"I've been with my partner for seven years
and sometimes I lie just a little to keep the peace.
For example", they write, "I watch full seasons of shows
and I don't tell him when I re watch them with him
as if it's just the first time," but that is awful.
"But recently his phone lit up
and I read three of his texts," maybe not so bad.
but then I also flipped through his notebook on his desk,
I feel terrible.
Do I tell him, so I come clean
and have a clean slate or do I just keep it to myself?
How do I stop myself from going
down this rabbit hole of a slippery movie thriller
signed desperately snooping in Chicago."
For starters, if you have to snoop
something's going on probably within you, agreed?
Agreed, I think it has,
I think this is all about this person,
not so much about the other person.
Yes, and I will also say the part
that I have a real problem with
is you watching a full season of a show.
If my Wellington, if he watched 90 day fiance,
without me, the wedding is off, you understand me?
That one really gets me going.
I will say that,
I think it is best to not snoop.
I think it it's a slippery slope
and I think you can get addicted to it.
And you can start conjuring up things
that you don't know, you gotta trust,
you gotta respect yourself and that other person.
So there's two different things at play here.
Maybe the watching the shows is kind of cute and innocent,
doesn't bother me, but the snooping I'd say cut it off
and just get confident because the person that you need
to work on is you, not them.
You can not control what other people do.
You can only control yourself.
And you wanna be the example of how people should behave,
not sitting there, like, you know, hating yourself
the whole time.
So move on, just move along and be respectful and let it go.
And if there's something burning and you're really
like suspicious of something
you can also listen to your inner gut on that.
Yeah, if there's something burning,
there's probably a cream for that.
(both laughing)
I hope we get more questions for advice column.
(upbeat music)